[Music]
hey welcome to every damn day mission
impossible fallout just came out and
Rotten Tomatoes just did a study where
they crunched the data in the movies
where Tom Cruise is running more tend to
do better at the box office and with
critics ratings so what do we make of
this does Tom Cruise running equal
box-office gold Ainslie can you play a
clip of that oh look at that Tom Cruise
run oh yeah this is from Rotten Tomatoes
oh you know it's gonna be a good movie
he's they've measured all the different
movies how much she actually runs on
screen and they calculated that in his
37 years of films he has run 24 thousand
feet on screen which is the equivalent
of four point five miles right this
makes total sense action movies are
better that's what's going on here
hey like action movies rich is run what
our discussion be better if one of you
were running during it do we have any
volunteers Jordan Jordan will do it okay
all right now let's please continue this
is a good idea so any other take please
disregard the Jordans running just treat
him like he's sitting here I feel like
he's in my shot so I'd prefer if he
wasn't what do you think hearing that
I'm like I should have put more running
in my web series I will say this I
haven't seen Mission Impossible my movie
past won't let me see it and that means
I'm probably not gonna get to see it so
I'm not gonna spend money on it even if
he is running I have a different theory
I feel like because Tom Cruise is so
short running makes him look taller yeah
so it's like women are more excited to
go Sam in those movies because he looks
way hotter I will say this Jordan looks
way hotter than usual by doing whatever
that is
it's like yeah running us like that is
the men's Barbie feet oh hi 80s she
didn't run very much and then he was
like uh turns out I'm much older now and
in way better physical shape so I should
run it all it's gotta be dude it's it's
crazy
he's fit sorry I've had moments where I
walked by Scientology and I'm like yeah
they're right across from Hamilton and
when I saw Hamilton I was like super
inspired and I was like maybe I should
just give my all my money to these
volcano monsters do you think the first
time Tom Cruise like realized that
moving was good in a movie was risky
business when he did that slide oh yes
it was at the beginning of the
revolution right yeah call sliding
Jordan once you have a seat I think you
get a great job good job Jordan Jordan I
think that just knocked off 5,000 views
in this video I think you just added a
billion dollars to that videos box
awesome
so it's time for some YouTube shoutouts
yesterday in the show we asked you to
roast us in honor of the roast so we
took to the YouTube community section
and this is what you said about us I
have a winner and I have an honorable
mention all right let's hear it right
you ready to go see okay this was I
thought was pretty clever Ryan looks
like Bradley Cooper if he suffered from
polio as a child that was written by
Katie Johnson Thank You Katie for the
roast and then well yeah this is a road
polio as a child doesn't this was from
Brad Denny Asterix I would have not been
the discussion but I did interview Nikki
Glaser so they said Hannah standing next
snaking shows everything you want in a
blonde and everything you don't and I
don't know if it was talking about our
looks because I'm sure it would throw to
Nikki but also I didn't speak so I'm
pretty sure is talking to me so I am
tired and don't speak a lot Chris it's
cool you enjoy sitting next to Jordan in
the office but be real dude it doesn't
matter where you sit you're still
sitting next to everybody in the office
the facts
that's a Chris fat yeah yeah okay I
chose Mike hunt mostly because it's
short I don't like words all right this
was at Ryan and Chris I love you guys
and comedy bang bang thank you Mike what
does that mean just read the comments
later okay
Natasha ah um I chose Ricardo C's
comment which I believe refers to Nate
who gave you that shirt El Chapo so I
like this just because there's a bit of
history involved so El Chapo I'm sure
you're familiar but is a famous Mexican
drug lord who's really well known also
for his shirts that have lots of fun
patterns on them
I believe that was a reference to your
banana I think you might be right
that's it is multiple prison escapes
Natasha and Jordan I like your
interpretations of the ensign menteur to
read Burns about other people mm our our
egos are to French yeah speaking of
fragile you guys this one was for me
this is from rock lover double-oh-seven
hey it's the loser from beauty and the
geek referring to me that was a reality
show that I was on on the CW a few years
ago but geek is too good a word for you
you look like a cross between Woody
Allen and the Gerber baby and so so far
I'm like okay this is only an okay burn
but then they really win me over the
last part I bet you'd win on beauty and
the face I'm here today with desi lydic
and Roy Wood jr. from The Daily Show and
we are talking The Daily Show with
Trevor Noah presents the Donald J Trump
Presidential Twitter library book guys
thank you so much for being here I'm
sorry this book it's so funny and what
is the daily show presence the Donald J
Trump Twitter library Wow can you
believe it that's what we're gonna be
talking about today it's a compilation
of all of the best and worse and
craziest tweets from our 45th president
yes it's the one book that he actually
wrote is there a favorite section of
yours within like the compilations we
have a whole section on Fox News and
it's like abundantly clear that his
tweets are verbatim what Fox News
so he's like clearly watching Fox News
and then just regurgitating it
word-for-word he's like he's doing the
work with transcribers exactly there's
also a great run in the book
we show all of the contradictions it's
called Trump versus Trump will say one
thing at one point in Twitter history
and then you can find a tweet that
directly contradicts what do you sit
just flip it is the only person who can
truly defeat Trump is Trump exactly like
yeah I really like there's like a
section where you analyze the tweets and
so there's data as well and then so I
didn't realize this but in 2015 you have
it that Trump tweeted nine thousand one
hundred and eighty two times mm-hmm
we also calculate it well not calculate
just went and pulled the data of who he
tweets who he's mentioned the most I
think he added Barack Obama number one
yeah I have it what is it two thousand
three hundred and forty four times he's
like the biggest Obama fan girl yeah
there is he also mentioned his daughter
Tiffany and Tiffany the jewelry store
Tiffany's the jewelry store the exact
same amount of times speaks volume yes
totally
I wonder if he also like would get them
confused probably when is he talking now
do you think this is a book best read
you know on the subway home on the
coffee table in the bathroom like where
do you think people should when they
purchase the book display it I feel like
you should read this book the same place
the president compose most of it is a
good size you know it was it was a very
intentional choice that it works
perfectly it sits right on the back of
the toilet huh have a seat
they're taking out take a read a quick
lead a short read whenever your needs
require that is true I wonder how many
Thanksgivings this book is gonna write
how many family reunion yeah it's good
say you start out reading this book to
your children yeah I really think that
because you know a lot of the tweets
read like a children's yeah so I think
you read some of this to your child so
you can teach them
right well what that logic looks like
this is like a book that can grow old
with you
absolutely I can time you read it
there's nuances that you missed before
you forget there's still like two more
years of president happening another
book do you think there's gonna be
another book do you imagine as long as
he keeps tweeting president or not this
is facet so you have to it's a silver
lining and all of this
speaking of silver lining do you think
in a way Trump has made books great
again he's made the desire to find
information I've never been more fat
checking obsessed society now than with
Trump so now we actually care I would
say he made this book great again once
again right yeah that's an excellent
answer
in fact Roy and I brought something for
you I'm like I am I just you don't have
to know your oh my god you're welcome
okay well well this is crazy I feel
silly cuz I got you this one oh my god
[Music]
my mom bought me this shirt
so it made me think of you because your
mom buys you supreme clothing set it to
my mom Rhonda you watch every episode I
appreciate it
big shadow rider dead my mom loves crazy
Chris I think is a very on the show you
know my mom also watches every we'll see
how the next episode
my back was good
[Music]
you